Boulder Highway built in 1931 to connect
Las Vegas to Henderson and Boulder City
now a very busy road and in need of a
major update Mary Jane beliesa explains
the improvements planned along Boulder
Highway
the project reimagined Boulder Highway
has been in the works for a few years
and is wrapping up the design stage the
project starts here in Henderson at
wagon wheel drive and continues seven
and a half miles past Gibson Road Scott
Martin a former police captain with the
Nevada Department of Public Safety now a
private investigator is excited to see
the changes as he used to patrol that
area as a former police officer I've
investigated
thousands of traffic accidents and I
have family that live on right off of
Boulder Highway pre-construction starts
in November converting Boulder Highway
to two travel Lanes in both directions
with additional Transit only Lanes in
the median and we're looking at
increasing the safety making it easier
for pedestrians for bicyclists for the
30 000 residents that live within a half
mile Boulder Highway project manager
Scott Jarvis of the reimagined Boulder
Highway project says this update is long
overdue as too many fatalities take
place along Boulder Highway each year he
hopes Redevelopment of this Corridor
will open up opportunities for
businesses and people to enjoy and move
in we are adding in added crosswalks at
a location for people to get from side
to side we're looking at modifications
to the side streets so there's not such
a long Crossing distance for pedestrians
I think it's important for everybody to
remember that it's a shared
responsibility amongst us all
pedestrians bicyclists drivers to ensure
that you're paying 100 percent full
attention to your driving the
construction phase is expected to start
on or before January 2024 and is
expected to end September 2025. Mary
June bellezza 8 News Now